[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  I thought we were your mother  trampolining  superheroes are illegal you wanna fight  bad guys defines Who I am  we're not saying you have what someone  on TV I was approached by this tycoon  most talked-about hero stuff help me  bring supers back into the sunlight  we need Elastigirl wants to do it I  don't know that way why would they  change math over Dusseldorf do those are  dogs yeah I was so happy to be closer I  couldn't have done this if you hadn't  taken over so well I've got to succeed  so she can succeed  cancer community bob is freaky but I  can't keep giving him cookies done  properly parenting is a heroic action  done properly  [Music]